the three day one we are having one hell
of a show I'm joined by Eric from the
turn director from dice on Mirror's Edge
catalyst so Eric what kind of a show is
this been for you guys it's been a
really great show so far we've you know
we showed the the trailer people of the
trailer
Sera's drove the press conference
everybody loved that and now they're
playing the game down at our booth and
people seem to love it so I'm very happy
so the original message was something of
a cult classic and it but kind of it we
never thought we'd see another one so
how did those discussions kind of go you
know what you guys to bring it back in
such a such a way I mean it's a game we
always wanted to bring back we always
wanted to continue what we started we
just wanted to do in the right way you
know everybody wanted to free roam in
the first game right and that's that's
one of the core things we wanted to do
and then there were lots of other stuff
that we just felt we needed to get right
yeah and also moving on to moving over
to frostbite engine and there was we'll
talk a little bit about frostbite
because that's what's helping give the
game it's gorgeous aesthetic but we'll
talk about that a bit yeah so catalyst
is Faith's
it's kinda like faiths origin story yeah
exactly this is it's a reboot of the
first game we're keeping lots of the
things we like from the first game but
we also wanted a kind of a clean slate
to be able to have a really stable
foundation to build on so this is this
is faiths origin story you get to see
how how she starts out as like a
carefree runner on the rooftops and then
gradually becoming a heroine so I mean
that's the thing the can don't confuse
me but I was I was expecting a straight
a sequel cuz the ending of the first
game no spoilers did leave things open
kind of a cliffhanger yes I see you guys
are kind of teasing us all there but I
am kind of glad to see we see how faith
became the amazing strong woman that she
is that's the idea yeah exactly
so that's what so let's talk a little
bit about the world yeah it has this
wonderful trade-off between looking
stunning pristine
but things under the surface and it's
not as it seems yeah underneath I mean
it's it's a beautiful world and at a
glance maybe it's supportive you
actually would want to live in but if
you just scratch the surface a little
you're gonna you know you're gonna see
it so it's a horrible place people are
under surveillance 100% of the time the
the conglomerate the authorities they
know where you are all the time and you
call everybody who lives in this world
is caught in this just this endless
cycle of basically work sleep consumed
and nothing else is tolerated and faith
obviously finds herself in that world as
a runner making sure that the
underground is getting getting upon
messages conversations are happening
exactly that that's I mean when the game
starts she's in a kind of a gray area
she's doing jobs for the corporations
she's doing jobs for the for the
resistance not really picking a side but
then because of events in the game she
gets caught in the conflict and and it
takes this takes picks aside and
hopefully the right side hopefully the
right side I think she picked the right
side so the game has moved from
basically a 3d platformer to open-world
yeah we like we like to think of it as a
free-roaming title yeah where freedom of
choice is the most important thing it's
still we've got a really strong story
that you know propels you through the
city but we've got lots of different
other things for you to do you know side
missions or just you know races or just
look at hunting for collectibles
exploring this beautiful world and so
it's gonna be like environmental puzzles
as well yeah lots of those I mean that
the game is about is about moving it's
about because you could interact with
anything you know if if you can climb on
anything you can run on anything jump
whatever you know so it's a lot about
looking at looking at the world you know
finding that spot way way over there you
know say will I be able to get there and
yeah and you can't yeah so how do you
kind of how do you keep the player on
track with the story then if everything
is free roam very spread out I mean the
the story is you'll always have a number
of objectives to play if you want to but
the player can always choose when to
continue with the story you know which
which missions will
tell them four words it's going to be
obvious for them we hope so let's talk a
little bit about frostbite because I
mean it's dices amazing revolution I
guess in terms of gaming and we have a
ton of games powered by for us by now
Mirror's Edge catalyst looks absolutely
certain we can see it here yeah what
what's the move to the engine been like
I mean we've we've been working on
frostbite for several years since this
bad company one it's it's an engine we
know and we have you know lots of
influence what we want to do with it and
you know where it would be down there
digging into it
are you still finding kind of new things
to do with it we're finding new things
to do we're adding new things to do it's
like there's a great cooperation with
the frostbite theme and ice and
obviously it has this beautiful
aesthetic let's talk a little bit more
about gameplay so yeah faith at least
when I was playing the original game I
like to think of her as just a free
runner she shouldn't have any kind of
want to do any gunplay I tried as best I
could to keep it was pretty hard it was
hard I mean you were rewarded if you
managed to do it sorry I couldn't what's
it gonna be like in catalyst so in
Mirror's Edge catalyst faith will never
use guns okay so you just won't have the
option it's all about using your speed
your momentum and and use using the
moves that you that you perform what was
just traversing the rooftops and and
combined it was a we've built the combat
system into that it's all about momentum
taking enemies down quickly efficiently
using your hands and feet how was the
pop core system change then I assume has
had a few tweaks upgrade its it's had
lots of tweaks it's still based on the
system and we players are the first game
we're gonna recognize it yeah but it's
it's just way smoother and there's just
way more things you can do once you
start experimenting with it it's just
it's a way more fluid system how have
you managed to incorporate I used to
play a feedback from the first game or
is it just been a buttload of play
tester so we have we have we listen to
feedback all the time we have we have
people you know from from the
coming and playing we look at them we
listen to what they say etc and then
there's lots and lots of play testing of
course and and also you know actually
just just new good ideas so why don't we
do this and then we try it and then you
know this is a you know if it's a good
idea we keep it are there any new kind
of moves that wouldn't be possible you
think that you know maybe if we push we
can make this happen this would look
really cool or this would be able to
cool to do or is it are you keeping it
kind of really rooted in something we're
kicking we're keeping it we can't be
it's rooted in freerunning or quite
parkour and but we've we've expanded on
the systems we're adding gadgets to the
game we're not talking about that yet
but we'll be talking about that more
later but it's still deeply rooted in in
freerunning and it's but it's a it's a
three year system it just feels free or
not yeah when you play it
let's talk finally just end on a v oz
big now it's a thing yes will Mirror's
Edge catalyst ever come to VR who knows
maybe it I think VR is great I love a
lot of stuff I think VR is you can't
just take Mirror's Edge and you know
slap they are on top of it imagine the
discrepancy between results so if we do
VR we're gonna make sure to do it right
that I can promise wonderful Eric thank
you so much for joining me
wonderful Mirror's Edge catalyst out
early next year be sure to stay here at
the GameSpot stage where we will be
having we've got one more big game
coming up today we are having one hell
of a time here through 2015 don't go
anywhere
you